who are you staying with right now are
you staying with family well yes I came
I came to see my mom and my my sister
who are here I'm not actually in the
same house as them one but yes I came to
see my mom my chain-smoking mother who
is assuring me that she's protecting
herself from coronavirus with the
smoking which she read on some dark web
protects you she thought she's gone from
smoking a pack of the day to now she's
up to probably two packs because she's
convinced it's um it's saving her life
and and she's read somewhere that in
France they even put nicotine patches on
Korona patients which I actually believe
I think it seems very French but I'm not
sure that she's I don't know whether her
theory is true and I keep saying to her
mom this is really worrying can you
please stop smoking and she says darling
her answer is darling I don't have a dry
cough I've got a very fruity cough
indeed which indeed she does this is let
me jump in here and just all due respect
to your mom this is terrible advice for
anybody out there you do not want to be
smoking and combat coronavirus there's
no evidence that I mean listen I don't
want to get into a fight with your mom
but she says it's who always wants to be
smoking coronavirus coronavirus is that
right yes she's just upset she's just
updated a lot and with and and now she's
she feels that she's totally within her
rights to close all the doors and all
the windows and you know expose us to
sort of second degree lung cancer while
she protects her own health by chains
okay now I know you have kids how are
your kids doing with the quarantine in
isolation are they okay they've been
really good and they've been very brave
and much more kind of stoic in a way
than anyone else but there are the odd
moments of lapses where me and my
husband were in there we're in I think
we were upstairs and they were
downstairs at one point in the midst of
and we heard our daughter who's 10 say
very loudly to our son who's 16
can you stop farting in my face I'm just
trying to survive here which I felt just
about summed up the experience I would
prefer your mom's cigarette smoke sorry
to look really really good to me